posture is very important when you're
wearing a structured piece like this
or else you just look like a folded
cardboard box it's different because
today i am just katy perry yeah katy
perry's mtv vma style may have looked
like that in the past
and this and this but this year
it looked a little something like this
let's go the 35 year old pop star
welcomed her baby girl daisy with fiance
orlando bloom
just last week and during sunday's
awards show the singer showed off what
new mom life
really looks like posting a mirror
selfie with her mock vma look to her
insta story
yeah that's a breast pumping bra and
some postpartum underwear people
and she's rocking it like a mama boss
oh thank you katie even joked in her
post quote hair and makeup by
exhaustion the song in the background a
track on her new album called
not the end of the world it's not the
end of the world
[Music]
mama's got jokes i do have a few
surprises
anyway katie did not attend this year's
vmas because she's recovering from
giving birth
and while the new mom seems to be
embracing her post-baby bod
earlier in the day she was a little
nostalgic for her pre-baby figure
katie shared this video on instagram and
wrote in the caption quote
listen to champagne problems to get your
pre-baby body back
[Music]
yep katie's still hard at work promoting
her new album
smile in addition to sharing that music
video katie also released the comic book
themed visual for her song
tucked i'll keep you tucked
[Music]
e.t caught up with katie last week
before her album was released
and before she gave birth i mean i don't
know who's going to come first her or
the record we'll see
what kind of headlines she wants she
wants a she wants to be the opener or
the closer
i have a feeling she does not follow
yeah
she was right daisy came wednesday and
the album dropped friday
and katie dished to e.t about the kind
of mama she wants to be
i'm just excited to be able to um
you know raise her
in a different way that i was raised and
to um
let her think for herself and have
choice
and you know discover
just you know just lean into the magic
of life and and
and probably you know dress what like
whatever she wants
to dress like for halloween that's going
to be really really important i was
never allowed to go trick-or-treating